bon ben la bombe emile ajar emile ajar
l'auteur de la vie devant soi les autres
que romain gary le célèbre écrivain la
trentaine d'ouvragés deux fois prix
concours recevoir deux fois le prix
goncourt pour un auteur c'est impossible
le règlement l'interdît c'est pourtant
ce qui est arrivé à romain gary
grâce à la plus grande et la plus belle
mystification de l'histoire de l'édition
française
son premier prix goncourt
romain gary le reçoit en 1956 pour les
racines du ciel mais romain gary et
doute dans son image d'écrivain établi
la célébrité du pèze la liberté de
l'anonymat lui manque
en 1974 il décide de signer son nouveau
livre gros câlin d'un pseudonyme emile
ajar
on ne sait pas qui est d'eyl c'est un
auteur mystérieux un romancier don c'est
apparemment le premier livre dont on
nous dit qu'ils habitent l'amérique du
sud pourquoi n'at-on pas vu de
photographies d'emile ajar mystère
complet
un mystère qui ne l'empêchent pas d'être
célébrée comme un grand écrivain et dès
l'année suivante c'est la consécration
pour son nouveau roman a été attribué au
8e tour à monsieur emile pour son roman
intitulé la vie devant toi
l'éditeur mercure de france jubile mais
le tout paris veut savoir qui se cache
derrière emile ajar sous pression romain
gary élaborent un plan
il demande à son cousin d'endosser le
rôle d'emile ajar paul pavlowitch donne
quelques rares interviews et refuse le
prix goncourt
si je me cache dit emile ajar ce n'est
pas tant dans l'espoir de préserver
quelques scandales policiers ou
littéraire quelconque mais parce que
j'ai besoin de préserver ma vie privée
map et carys lui défend le désir
d'anonymat de son cousin sur les
antennes dans ce qui semble aujourd'hui
une véritable confession de son
subterfuge un homme le connaît bien
emile ajar en tout cas son oncle son
oncle
romain gary partir d'un certain degré
une autorité le type deviennent trop
jaune de leur image 1980
romain gary se suicide
paul pavlowitch révèle le secret à jara
l' agence france-presse
puis se livre dans un entretien
confession sur le plateau d' apostrophes
je sentais bien qu'il me manipuler mais
d'abord j'étais là pour être manipulé en
1981 par les un livre posthume de romain
gary
vie et mort d'emile ajar ses derniers
mots sont je me suis bien amusé au
revoir et merci
[Musique]